hi there today we're looking at long
former the long document transformer by
is belt adji matthew peters and armand
cohen of allen AI so the long former is
a variant of the transformer as you
might have guessed the long former is a
transformer that can deal with long
documents so it's aptly named so I am
going to discuss what differentiates the
long former from the transformer if you
don't know what a transformer is watch
the video on attention is all you need I
have a video on that and I would also
suggest you watch the video on Burt
because a lot of the architecture and
training here is based on the on the
Burt or variants of Burt
so I'll mace basically explain what
makes the long former different such
that it gets long documents right so she
can be applied to long documents right
so what is the problem or the original
transformer if you have a transformer
model and let's say you're doing an NLP
tasks which usually is where
transformers are used and you won't have
a paragraph like this one right here the
abstract of the paper and maybe want to
predict whether the paper gets accepted
at a conference or not now the classic
transformers they D they have a limit a
very harsh limit on the amount of tokens
that they can look at at the same time
so what you would do in a classic
transformer is you couldn't process this
entire thing let's say you would divide
it in chunks you'd say okay here's my
first chunk from here to here my second
chunk from here to here and then here to
here and so on so you go through the
documents split it up in chunks process
each of the chunks individually and then
maybe aggregate the predictions but of
course the drawback is that the model
cannot make specific connections between
let's say some word
here like operation and somewhere down
here like language it cannot connect the
two on a neural level at least not in
the classic transformer architectures
now there are ways to try to alleviate
this but classically if you split up
your documents into individual samples
they become independent you cannot do
attention this attention mechanism
cannot operate over it across the
boundaries of these chunks so the long
former the goal is to actually just in
just be able to put this entire document
here into the model at the same time so
let's look a bit closer into this in a
classic transformer model what you'll
have is you'll have layers of what are
what is called attention mechanism I'm
gonna draw six units here and the units
are actually the input sequence so in a
transformer other than like a classic
neural network you don't actually have
numbers of units in the in in the layers
but you can input as many as long
sequences as you want until your memory
limit is reached basically so these
units they expose something called keys
on the lower layer and these are vectors
that you know point somewhere and the
upper layer will produce what are called
queries and again I invite you to look
at the attention is all you need video
if you want more explanation and
basically the keys and queries they
decide where information gets routed to
right so the routing of information is
what makes the transform of the
transformer so for example this here is
probably gonna be routed to this here so
the information is routed like this and
then this here is going to be routed
like this you see the routing is
according to the dot product of the of
the keys and queries right so in essence
if you
in input sequence tokens and you usually
transform in a transform you transform
the things into same length sequences
that has to do a lot also with how you
want to pre train things and so on so
we're not really gonna change that part
if you have n input sequence and n
tokens on the next layer and everything
can attend to everything so all the
inner products are computed right
everything is connected to everything
that means that you're going to end up
with an O of N squared memory
requirement because you have N squared
connections the way to alleviate this is
much much like you would alleviate this
in a classic neural network so in a
classic neural network imagine you have
this MLP a multi-layer perceptron or
what usually known as a fully connected
layer right so here I have the same
thing but it's not a transformer it's a
classic neural network fully connected
so I have D units right here and D units
in this first hidden layer and I'll have
a weight matrix in here right and the
weight matrix means everything is
connected to everything right everything
connects to everything else again my
memory requirement here is d squared now
how do we deal with this in a classic
neural network we go to what is called a
convolutional neural network at least
that's one of the one of the methods so
let's make this again but let's now make
this a convolutional neural network what
we'll have is will have a convolutional
kernel in this case it's just of length
three right so we just have three units
here and they will do the same fully
connected pattern but only over these
three units right here and then we slide
the kernel over right now it's in this
position it's still the same three units
but now these three things are connected
to these three things that they're now
over right
so you keep sliding this over across the
lower layer until you're finally at the
end here and now you've reduced the
memory consumption from d squared to
just D times and if this is usually the
kernel size is called K to D times K and
K you can keep pretty much constant so
that's all of D right and the same goes
for the long form so in the long former
the idea is that you have a so called
sliding window attention it's exactly
the same as it is in the convolution
except that you don't have these hidden
units here but these are actually seek
the parts of the input sequence and
instead of the weight matrix here you
have the attention mechanism over the
keys queries and values but the idea is
similar so you can basically say this is
a sort of a convolution and we've
already had this in the video about
axial attention a bit now of course this
is is your trade-off memory for
performance because before right before
I'm gonna draw let's draw it on top of
this fully connected layer before all
the units could attend to all the units
right and now the unit can only attend
to its immediate neighborhood right this
green unit here can only attend to
itself in the lower layer and its
immediate neighbors if the kernel size
is 3 but consider what happens in the
next layer so in the next layer I have
for example this unit right here is the
same unit right on the next layer it can
attend to these two and itself in the
lower layer but these two themselves can
attend to all of these right so that the
one on the right can attend to one more
so in the first layer this particular
unit had information from these three
units but in the second layer
the same unit has now information across
these five right and this is kind of
this cone of attention it gets bigger
and bigger as you go through the layers
so you lose the information to
incorporate wide ranges of information
in a single layer
but you regain it through depth right
the deeper you go the more a single unit
gets information right this unit gets
information from this unit over here
through the layers through the layers it
can't it can't watch the unit right here
in this layer that's not possible but it
gets the information through the layers
of course there's still a trade of like
a fully connected layer could just do
this in one step and then in the next
layer it could do it again right it can
do much more complex computation but if
you believe that the most important
information is actually in the
neighborhoods of the individual tokens
which is conceivable in something like
the convolutional neural network you
know that you know in an image usually
you have localized information right if
there's a cat here then the nose and the
eyes of the cat they're pretty close
together so in order to recognize it's a
cat you want mostly want local
information or a more local information
so in an image that makes sense in in a
text it also makes sense to a degree in
that usually words close together in a
sentence they they are important to for
each other right but the power of the
transformer was initially that it could
attend to everything in a sentence right
so for example if you have again the
paragraph here the power of the
transformer at least that was said is
the fact that this this piece of text
here could make a connection to this
piece of text here and therefore the
understanding of the entire paragraph
could be reliant on this connection
being made which a local model can't do
but if you go through depth that you
might be able to recover that
so the long former is basically what the
convolutional neural network does for
MLPs it does it for transformers right
so instead of n-by-n giving you n
squared now you go into into this way
where you have so if you do the same for
the transformer you go to O n times
let's call it W and W being your window
size in this case they have a
illustration of this right here so in a
original transformer this is an
attention matrix so here you have your n
units in sequence and drawn-in is which
unit can attend to which other unit in a
given layer so you'll see this
particular unit I here can attend of
course to itself right can attend to
unit I but it can also attend to this
unit or to this unit or to this unit to
any unit right and that's what gives you
this N squared attention because any
unit can attend to any unit now in this
sliding window attention pattern and
this is one of the core components of
the long former you see that the I is
unit here right here can attend to
itself right but also to this and to
this this but no more it can only attend
to the eyuth unit or two I minus W 2 I
plus W right and this here is a window
of size W this is this sliding window so
given unit can only attend to itself or
its neighbors in one layer right and
this is exactly what a convolution is
like if you see if you see this pattern
this is a this is
pattern now the second core component is
they expand on this idea in that they
make they create these dilated sliding
windows now you see you already know
what a sliding window is now they're
saying well if you if you have this
sliding window it might take quite a
number of layers in order to you know
get your attention of the entire
sequence incorporated we saw before it
took like three layers to get halfway
through this sequence of what was it
like six tokens and it took us like
three layers and with so basically if
you go if you go one layer up right one
layer up you gain one more context
window in each direction right so it's
not that you'd have to go very very deep
in order to incorporate the information
from these very long sequences and the
sliding the dilated sliding window helps
this where they say well technically now
any any any sequence here so again if we
have this sequence and this is the next
layer let's just draw so this unit right
here it will be able to attend this and
this but not this and not this but it
will also be able to attend this and
this but not this and not this sorry not
this so it'll skip one so right these
these attention patterns they will
always kind of skip skip one and the
idea is that now you have a vastly
greater window of attention right your
window size is now way bigger that means
you can incorporate information way
faster across the layers like global
information but of course now they're
kind of arguing against each other in
when they do this sliding window they
say well we pose that mostly local
information is important for NLP right
the words right around the word are
important and now if they say this here
they basically say oh well it's not so
important that we miss this word right
here which is right next to the world
that they are attending from which is
counter counter to what they just said
that probably the most important
information is around the word they they
do get around this by saying well if we
have different layers in a transformer
and in the lower layers
we'll use this sliding window fully
local and in the higher layers will use
this dilated window and therefore in the
in the lower layers we postulate that
local information is actually what's
needed to understand local features and
then in the higher layers we want more
global information because it will
incorporate features from the from the
local informations of the lower layers
all right I can I can get the
argumentation but I feel that's just
something they've thrown in there to
make it work better after they tried it
out and the the last idea here in the
long form is what they call global
attention and these global attention is
ours what it means is that there are
some special units here so in this this
this in this unit and these special
units as you can see from the attention
pattern these are these can actually
attend to everything so this unit can
attend for example to this one or to
this one or to anything these can attend
to anything and any unit can attend to
those right any unit can attend to the
first unit right here right so these are
your special tokens your special units
and they have global attention and the
reason for the
particularly is that sometimes this is
needed and this is an engineering choice
the example I can give is let's say you
have a question answering tasks in a
question answering task what you usually
have is a question and a paragraph and
let's say the task here is to answer yes
or no is that is the question it's a
question might be a statement right uh I
don't know
King James was King of England from 1120
to 11:40 and then the paragraph will be
the Wikipedia entry for King James and
the the question is yes or no is the is
a question true or not is the statement
made true or not how you would feed this
to a bird model to a transformer is you
concatenate these two things question
query our statement and paragraph right
these are the tokens right here and then
you would separate them using a special
token called the separator token this is
just to inform the model that here is
where the first thing stops and the next
thing starts and then at the beginning
you would put a special token called the
CLS token now usually what you do is you
send these things through your
transformer and now in the last layer
right you end up as we've seen before
because you always transform a sequence
into a sequence you end up with a
sequence again but you just want a
single thing you just want yes or no so
you designate you say this particular
unit here that corresponds to the CLS
token that's what I'm going to throw
into a logistic regression and that's
what will give me my yes or no answer
and that's how you train it right so you
have you don't want to single out any of
these for any of these as like special
so you simply already include a special
token at the beginning that then you
take the classification from right it's
pretty smart but also you say ah this is
such a special token I want that
to be able to attend to anything right
even though for example this unit right
here it can only attend to its neighbors
right it has this cone thing and this
unit right here has this cone thing this
unit right here can always attend to
anything at each of the layers right it
can attend to anything and anything can
attend to it so it can get information
from anywhere routed to it in each of
the layers and it can send information
to any of the other units and this is an
engineering choice
so at the beginning you as an engineer
have to say which one of these tokens
are special tokens and for these tokens
you'll actually then do full attention
right it can attend to and from anything
so what are our new memory requirements
what this will give us is first of all
we have n tokens right and here W is our
window size so we have n times W memory
but then we also add the global
attention so plus the number of special
tokens times right so number if there's
a special token it will have n times 2
memory requirement because it can attend
from + 2 in each layer so and this
entire thing sorry with the Plus this
entire thing times the number of layers
so this is your new attention memory
requirements and as you can see here n +
n so this is going to be order of n
instead of much smaller than order of N
squared as we had for the original
transformer right so this this is what
the the long former basically does now
they have written custom CUDA kernels
for doing this for doing this this
dilated attention and so on which is
pretty cool and they have code available
for the model
they test this on a number of language
tasks and they what I find interesting
is it actually they start from the
Roberta checkpoint which Roberta where
is it said somewhere oh yeah this is
this Roberta model right here is a
variant of Burt all right you can see
the name in here is a variant of Burt
and that's their their baseline and they
start from these checkpoints as far as I
understand in that it kind of copy over
the position embeddings and so on and
therefore they only need to train not
very much posture Roberto now the reason
why they can copy it over actually is
and this I find very interesting is they
use a window size of 512 so until I read
this I got away from reading the paper
thinking that this this window size here
might be fairly small right so this
window size it might be you know maybe
10 20 30 tokens or something right but
actually this window size is 512 in
there in their formulation which
basically means that this is this is as
much as one of the classic models could
take as a document right so sorry let's
go so this this here is 512 so this is
what a classic model could take as as a
as an entire document and in the classic
model you simply split up the document
feed chunks right and then aggregate
over them now the long former basically
has this so right now for now I said it
has less memory requirement actually has
the same memory requirements as a
classic model but it is also able
because of these global attention to
kind of incorporate information from the
surrounding things so that's the the new
part because if you think about
if this w here is 512 512 was the
original n so 512 was the N 0 whatever
the old models had as an N so right now
if I replace this and let's let's you
know don't not take care of this if I
replace this it's actually n times n 0
and that regresses to the classic model
if you plug in and 0 here right so the
new part really is the fact that you
have this this sliding window and the
global attention is is able to
incorporate information from these
special tokens as well because sliding
window that was done before so I just
don't want you to get to you the wrong
impression that now we can run
transformers on like very small memory
machines we can't but we can run them on
the same memory machines because this is
the same length right but also feeding
longer documents and have some
information of the entire document be
propagated to these to these blocks
which before we couldn't before we could
just simply feed these blocks as one and
not have global information so that's
that's the new thing at least they
haven't tested it on the smaller things
which is cool from an engineering point
right you would want to as if you want
to show that you're better you would
want to basically be able to be as
powerful as the old model but then be
more powerful and that's what they do
all right so if you want to check out
the experiments and the ablations is
very interesting because they they turn
on and off a lot of things in their
model and kind of check out where things
come from what helps what doesn't and
I'll leave this to you and I'll link it
and with that thanks for listening
watching and bye bye